I want to take 1 minute
to respond to the provocations of the
Turkish President Erdogan
that tries regularly,
I say tries
regularly,
to humiliate us by threatening to conquer the West,
he who
in the of the despicable 07/10 attacks in Israel,
dared to launch us,
the West,
do you want to resume the
fight between the cross and the croissant ?
Then
I tell him
in your name,
attention,
Attention Erdogan,
we too have our pride,
we also know where we come from
and where we are going.
We know that we have
one thousand five hundred years of history to defend.
So Mr.
Erdogan,
stop your
and remember our victories in Poitiers,
to the slopes,
to vies.
Europe is still alive and will never be
neither conquered nor subdued.